bonjour is 6 13. today is national girls
and women in sports day it's an
annual day every year to acknowledge the
accomplishments of female athletes alex
yes we have such great female athletes
here in las vegas bianca holman
live with reaction from some of our
local women in sports hi bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
so yeah normally here there would be
lots of kids boys and girls playing a
variety of sports basketball
swimming and you know even soccer so
but things are different but often times
there'll be more boys than girls so this
is the day that we're encouraging more
girls to get active in sports
girls and women in sports day and so
again we were able to talk with some
leaders in sports here in our community
there's actually a report by a women's
sports foundation
that shares their gender gaps in sports
participation from the number of players
to the compensation
the organization also notes there are
several benefits when girls do get
active
they learn important life skills like
leadership and teamwork the group
actually found that 75 percent of
working women feel that sports helped
them build
confidence we caught up with the unlv
track and field director
at the first silver state cross country
competition
coach yvonne wade shares that she has
definitely big hopes for the future
of women in sports i think there's more
and more women getting into roles that
they didn't think that they
could do before you know we have an
amazing athletic director at unlv with
desiree reid francois
and she's the first of many to come and
she's a great leader and inspiration for
our young girls
i have a women's team that i try to make
sure that they're uplifted and get to do
the things they want to do and so many
want to be coaches afterwards so
you know we just kind of keep pushing
them to reach for the stars
most definitely and so there's a virtual
girls fest this year it's hosted by
women in sports foundation
foundation it's going to be streamed on
their youtube page lots of special
guests they've got olympic gold
medalists
and other award winners like a
paralympic swimming medalist
and if you've got a girl athlete in the
house you definitely want to tune in and
she's got to definitely tune
in to this also coming up in the next
half hour we're going to hear from
one of our las vegas aces players and i
will tell you during
high school i played basketball and i
was also involved in dance but i was not
good but it definitely helped me build
confidence
and not be afraid to try new things
reporting live bianca holman
i did basketball and dance too and
bianca you know how short i am
my basketball career was very
short-lived but
yes it's nice were you a point guard
alex you had to be a point guard right
i was yes i tried i was a small forward
i was either four or the five
okay let's see i can see you doing well
there it's nice to see other women
though doing it well
for long periods of time so thanks
bianca we'll see you at 6 30.
sure